you're 11 and 12 like we just finished
the topic cold well we look at ya
differentiation and stuff right
tangents and normals which is really
right
like kind of the first main part in a
12-course meal that is calculus right
and calculus is the big thing with this
course really like we've just chosen it
and we're just going to go keep deeper
and deeper going into it in the rest of
year now geometry at least like
deductive geometry which is what this is
really short for deductive geometry
where you have to like construct cruson
all I kind of think obviously is
connected to this because
differentiation at least we've seen is
about gradient saw which is a geometric
thing but the whole making a proof and
what-have-you doesn't really cook here
to this like differentiation is can you
calculate something and they can use
that result rather than can you just
prove something is true or not so this
is an easy option to get rid of now I'm
actually going to do something to put
you on the spot I want you to imagine if
you were in my shoes and you're like
okay we have this topic that's in the
senior math syllabus why would you keep
this topic if it's one of the least
connected to the rest of what you're
doing what's useful or interesting about
that would make you want to keep it okay
so it's a challenge it's a serious
challenge right okay we'll talk about
that in a second one of you some tips
but yes in some ways you can it has a
bit of a reputation for being highly
technical right Doris did you wanna make
suggestions it makes you think
differently okay before we leave off
that and give get your suggestion wrap
unless it was in a solving I want to
push on that idea a little bit it makes
you think differently who wants to give
a suggestion as to in what way because I
think that's true but it's also very
broad they want to take a stab okay okay
so there's a lot of visual stuff right
it's intensely visual I think if the
opposite of like what's the most like
numerical type thing you're doing right
like maybe algebra is highly simple
like okay and so this is kind of like
the opposite end of the scale the scale
right and we're gonna talk about like
yeah you need pictures and kourin's all
that kind of thing so that's a different
thing about it any other things that are
different about geometry that are
crucial in this something okay yeah it's
like okay we are surrounded by like you
can see geometry because it's a visual
and so it's all over the place right
like we are standing in a river is full
of geometry it couldn't have been made
without geometry right RAF you had your
head up before do you have a different
suggestion
okay sir in case you didn't catch that
this in fact might be the field they fit
and I care two guys under thinking
differently right the first proof is
really the big idea that geometry is
getting at which you know we prove
things in differentiation but we're like
proof was developed as an idea and we're
like mathematical logic really matured
was in geometry is in geometry
so the Greek math addition Euclid right
who this field is named after Euclidean
geometry if you heard that phrase I
figured that that logic to constructor
proof that's really that's really the
reason why deductive geometry is in a
course which mostly has to do in
calculus right it's because proof is
such a like if you did all if you went
through 13 years in mathematics and
never really learnt the rigors of how to
prove something and have it without a
shadow adapt be true and understand
illogical pieces that put it then you
haven't really learned mathematics right
so that's why we're doing this this is
not just about memorizing a whole set of
like rules and the exact wording all
that kind of thing it's about this like
I'm not a massive milestone in
mathematics